pour alexandre langlois merci de
répondre à nos questions sur leur télé
france donc la médecine de prévention a
validé le fait que vous puissiez porter
des masques
comment est ce que vous allez utiliser
cette autorisation bon l'accueil avec
plaisir déjà parce que c'est nos
délégués cas responsable de la santé
pour les policiers qui a fait la demande
il ya maintenant plus d'une semaine
auprès de toutes les directions dont la
direction de la médecine de prévention
est la seule réponse que nous avons eue
c'est la médecine de prévention qui a
autorisé le port des masques lavables il
faut savoir que nous avions également
réussi à retrouver des entreprises qui
pouvaient nous fournir des masques des
usagers des gens qui soutiennent la
police pourront fabriquer des masques
pour la police mais nous avions
l'interdiction administrative de les
porter et en fait c'est sera pas
forcément l'idéal ces masques là mais ce
sera toujours mieux que rien pour nous
protéger donc enfin ça bouge un petit
peu et on peut constater à leurs
reportages voulait passer c'est que même
les politiques de différentes villes
sont en train d'adopter ces mesures
donc une fois de plus nous sommes à la
ramasse dans la police nationale et le
tarn employeurs qui est complètement à
contre-courant des skis préconisée par
les spécialistes
on parle de masques lavables ainsi son
idée masques chirurgicaux ni des masques
ffp2 pourquoi est ce qu'on parle de
système d ici là on parle de système d
oui parce que le masque lavables donc a
été c'est un protocole qui a été validé
par le chu de grenoble que nous avons
repris ensuite le chu de strasbourg et
la médecine de prévention combien
précisé que ces masques aulas n'était
pas adapté pour toutes les missions dans
certains cas il fallait vraiment des
masses que je suis un des masques ffp2
ou chirurgicaux après comme on en a pas
pour le moment de toute façon ce sera
mieux que rien et là bas parce que l'on
avait également fait un recours au
niveau de l'ue conseil d'état référé
pour demander l'arrêt de la destruction
des masques en france parce qu'on
pourrait être conditionnée une partie
des masques quant aux pénuries toutes
les méthodes sont bonnes pour permettre
aux gens de travailler en sécurité et
éviter la propagation du virus dans un
communiqué de votre syndicat on lit que
des policiers reçoivent des dons de
masse mais que votre hiérarchie
administrative vous interdis de
2 les portes et pourquoi selon vous
c'est toujours pareil quand nous avons
un ministre va des ministres et
secrétaires déterministe qui sont
complètement dépassés par la situation
et des directeurs qui vivent la réalité
de terrain dans des bureaux des
syndicats majoritaires qui propose des
solutions de salon pas finalement c'est
les gens qui sont sur le terrain qui
peuvent apporter les réelles solutions
mais ça leur fait mal en fait la saveur
fait mal qu'on ait raison et d'autant
plus je vais donner dans l'est de la
france donc il l'épicentre de l'épidémie
en france
les collègues d'autres syndicats qui ont
distribué des masques dans leur brigade
valeur brigades sont toujours debout à
100%
voilà ils ont été contre leur hiérarchie
et dans un commissariat
par exemple 70 % de nos collègues sont
en confinement suspecté d'être malade
donc seulement disponible à cause du
courant d'un virus les seuls brigade qui
fonctionne celle où nous délégués ont
fait leur travail
et bien justement disant aux collègues
porter des masques protéger votre santé
et arrêtez d'écouter des gens qui sont
juste là pour la communication des
primes en fait la santé est primordiale
d'autant plus que vous pouvez ramener le
virus chez vous ou et eu un vecteur de
propagation auprès de la population
donc c'est contre-productif et quand on
compare les photos de policiers de tous
les pays du monde qui sont touchés par
le coronavirus nous sommes les seuls les
seuls à pas porter de masque avait pensé
à passer pour des clowns dans le monde
entier récemment le chiffre de dix mille
policiers à l'arrêt était évoqué on a
parlé de plus de 300 agents contaminé
également quels sont les chiffres
aujourd'hui exactement est-ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de cas de contamination chez
les policiers
c'est comme partout les chiffres dans
d'autres ministères sont souvent truqués
trafic et donc c'est malheureux on ne
sait pas de chiffres exacts donc
effectivement la proportion enfle c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont obligés de
communiquer nous avons déjà deux
collègues qui sont morts à collègues
actifs et une collègue administratif
donc ça prend des proportions énormes et
pour le moment les mesures pour nous
protéger ne sont toujours pas là et
protéger la population ce que nous
sommes en contact de différentes
personnes au cours de la journée donc
nous sommes aussi les vecteurs
potentiels
donc pour le moment la situation ne va
que s'aggraver et pour le moment il n'y
a pas vraiment de mesures prises en
avant à part justement nous dire
durcissent et les contrôles durcissent
et tout mais en n'ayant pas les moyens
de le faire donc c'est très compliqué de
travailler dans des conditions pareilles
car la france a besoin de policiers mais
deux policiers qui sont valides et qui
sont capables de faire leur travail
vous avez parlé de chiffres trafiqués
vous avez des preuves bas les chiffres
trafiqués c'est que c'est au début
travaillant dans un service de
renseignement les chiffres étaient
toujours un décalage d'une semaine c'est
à dire qu'on nous disait tout va bien et
puis finalement il y avait déjà cette
carte
finalement quand il ya les sept cas ont
été annoncés il y en avait 100 donc en
fait on est toujours en décalage par
rapport à la réalité
alors pour des spécialistes de la
communication qui sont capables de faire
des annonces dans les médias avant que
les notes de service arrive on trouve
que bah du coup pour les chiffres c'est
l'inversé que bas les chiffres arrivent
dans les services avant et on a une
réalité qui est bien différente en
général avec une semaine de décalage
merci alexandre l'anglo d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire général du syndicat de
police à vigy là